[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
une émission pour vous présenter les
projets culturels dans les yvelines qui
se poursuivre malgré le confinement
au programme aujourd'hui elle a
participé à the voice en 2014 dans la
team de jennyfer sara jade serait avec
nous sur le plateau la chanteuse nous
présentera son tout premier ep sorti en
février dernier
il est composé de quatre types au style
pop rock le groupe et binoy carnage
opéra vient également de sortir un
nouvel ep revenir 2 il fait partie d'un
triptyque dont le premier volet sorti en
janvier dernier et les six nouveaux
morceaux sont disponibles en ligne
gratuitement
et puis les piles équipe artistique du
spectacle variété a répété à la scène
nationale pour présenter la pièce aux
professionnels l'équipe s'est engagée
dans un nouveau projet la réalisation
d'un film de théâtre pour le public et
je vous le disais en titre sara jade
chanteur compositeur compositrice pardon
et auteur est avec nous en plateau
bonsoir à soir justin vous êtes avec
nous pour nous présenter votre tout
premier europe et le personnel il est
sorti en février je vous propose de
regarder un extrait d' american life on
en parle juste après
on
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors american life c'est un morceau qui
parle un peu du rêve américain
est ce que c'est un titre qui vous fait
écho personnellement et quel est le
message que vous avez voulu transmettre
oui c'est un c'est un titre qui me fait
écho puisque puisque c'est moi qui
l'écrit déjà et que c'est un message de
liberté que j'ai envie j'avais envie de
faire passer un message de liberté et de
de lâcher prise aussi et puis passer un
message dynamique positif quelque chose
qui rassemble les gens fédérateur aussi
pour pour pallier un petit peu à ce
manque de communication qu'on a en ce
moment
et justement parler d'écriture on
découvre dans ce nouvel ep vos talents
d'auteure compositrice qu'est ce qui
vous a poussé à vous lancer
alors ça fait quand même très longtemps
que j'écris j'ai écrit pour d'autres
d'autres projets et ce projet là en
particulier
oui j'avais envie de le faire depuis
longtemps et ce qui m'a poussé c'était
une rencontre avec les personnes à qui
je travaille aujourd'hui et vous avez un
style alors un peu pop rock à
l'américaine un univers qui fait écho je
pense notamment à pink de la chanteuse
quelles sont vos influences en général
et sur ce nouvel opus
alors c'est vrai que pink heures revient
souvent comme comme référence et et je
suis absolument fan de cet artiste donc
sa tente dans le mime et puis c'est vrai
que ça brille ça me on voit bien que on
entend bien que voilà que je les aime
bien
et pour citer d'autres références je
dirais je dirais que ce qui compose la
musique aujourd'hui c'est un mélange de
soul de pop de rock
j'ai pas vraiment j'ai vraiment beaucoup
d'artistes que j'affectionne beaucoup et
tout tout tout tout ce mélange a fait
que c'est ma musique aujourd'hui voilà
et pouf mélange l'apc nouvel ep alors
voilà américaine
et pour ce nouvel album ses morceaux
sont tous chantés en anglais
pourquoi ce choix alors choix
complètement assumé déjà pour commencer
et parce que c'est aussi ma culture
musicale et que j'ai baigné j'ai baigné
dans la culture musicale américaine
anglo saxon
c'est aussi une langue qui sonne bien je
trouve avec ma voix et j'ai travaillé
pour ça aussi donc voilà je c'est une
façon d'être universelle où s'est lui
aussi aussi c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que l'anglais c'est la langue
universelle et que ça peut toucher
beaucoup de monde donc ce projet ce
nouveau projet est ce que c'est un
aboutissement est ce que c'était une
évidence finalement d'en arriver là
aujourd'hui
oui c'est un aboutissement peut le dire
oui c'est
il fallait que je le fasse c'était
nécessaire pour moi de le faire pour
être une artiste accomplie
et est ce que vous avez de nouveaux
projets pour la suite
projet ces deux projets vraiment c'est
de défendre dès qu'on pourra ses
chansons sur scène aujourd'hui sur cet
ep il ya quatre titres mais il ya
d'autres chansons qui existe déjà et
qu'on a déjà défendu sur scène
auparavant et de continuer à voile à
promouvoir à se développer
voilà on recherche aussi peut-être des
gens qui pour nous aider à développer à
grandir et vous avez peut-être retrouver
le public pour présenter surveille ce
nouvel ep
mon dieu oui oui oui les prochaines
dates peut être à venir on sait pas
encore alors pour l'instant on ne sait
pas encore on a un peu de visibilité
peut-être à la rentrée on a on va
travailler sur des résidences d'ailleurs
pas très loin d'ici à la batterie dans
cette salle superbe qui est la batterie
où on va pouvoir travailler notre autre
chose et être prêts dès qu'on pourra
merci beaucoup et sarah jade d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir je le rappelle votre
nouvel ep à sara jade est disponible en
ligne et notamment sur votre site
internet qui est sa rage à deux points
comme merci beaucoup
[Musique]
on reste dans la musique avec revenir 2
le nouvel ep du groupe yvelinois carnage
opéra il est sorti le 18 mars en ligne
et les fait partie d'un triptyque
musicales dont le premier volet est
sorti en janvier dernier elle les six
nouveaux morceaux sont disponibles en
ligne gratuitement un nouvel ep aux
styles musicaux variés voici un extrait
de quelque chose doit changer suivi de
l'interview du chanteur auteur et
compositeur christian pour regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et dès juillet
jour 7
[Musique]
les nôtres
six morceaux il y en a pas deux qui se
ressemblent ça va du très pêchue quand
quelque chose doit changer au très
sombre comme la plaine ou plus dont il
dit comme le goût des larmes et voilà et
se balader dans ces univers où nous on
fait des longs plat la musicale aussi
parce qu'on aime ça
elles s'en sont imprégnés de cette
ambiance mais aucune ne parle
directement depuis une crise sanitaire
ou c'est plutôt s'exprime plutôt des
ressentis dans la situation mais aussi
le ressenti ce sentiment tout vous avez
des gens qu'on aime et c'est déjà
compliqué les aimer toutes ces choses là
en fait qu'on traverse à tous
[Musique]
c'est certain que parce que j'ai le
confinement et parce que nous on est en
tant qu'intermittent dans les spectacles
de spectacle vivant
on est complètement bloquée on peut plus
bouger de chez nous bah du coup
effectivement là oui ça l'est lui laisse
du temps pour créer
notre intention si vraiment on veut
reprendre ce que les gens appellent une
vie normale mais surtout une vie quoi
c'est de peut-être réunir les trois ep
dans un album qui sera physique cette
fois ci ce sera vraiment un cd vinyles
on hésite encore avec un concert de
sortie c'est carrément revenir quoi
revenir 2 est disponible en ligne et
gratuitement sur l'épreuve les
plateformes le troisième ep revenir
trois donc elle devrait sortir courant
juin le festival à tout bout de champ
été annulée cette année à cause de la
crise sanitaire mais certains événements
ont été maintenus en ligne et c'est le
cas notamment pour le concert contre
brassens à l'ombre du coeur le spectacle
sera retransmis en ligne sur les réseaux
sociaux de la ville de man il est à bout
ça se passe ce dimanche 28 mars à 17
heures la chanteuse pauline dupuis
interprétera à des chansons du
répertoire de georges brassens parlons
coloriage à présent ce mot évoque
souvent une activité pour les plus
petits mais les adultes s'y mettent
aussi ardemment et illustrateur unis
montrent un il a créé un livre de
coloriage
il y a quelques mois célia get on go
vous faudra qu'on soit vous êtes avec
nous justement vous avez rencontré cette
artiste et je vois que vous avez le
livre entre vos mains oui oui le feu le
nom de ce livre de coloriage pour
adultes s'appelle le hybridation
d'ailleurs ce sont des coloriages de
tous types parce que par exemple celui
ci sont destinées aussi pour les enfants
alors il est disponible en meute aux
éditions sur amazon et souvent les
thèmes de livres de coloriage sont assez
reposant comme la nature ou les mandalas
et bien ardam lui a voulu prendre le
contre-pied en proposant des thèmes non
pas classique mais plutôt singulier
regarde et je me suis dit je vais
prendre deux éléments qui sont
radicalement opposés alors ça peut être
n'importe quoi ça peut être
où est charlie et des squelettes ou
des chiens et
des bonbons enfin n'importe quoi et puis
voir ce que ça donne quand je télescope
ces univers là si ça me fait rire si si
c'est intéressant si j'arrive à trouver
des idées dessus donc voilà c'est un
livre sur du télescopage d'idées à
colorier alors il ya aussi eu des mini
séries
dans ce livre par exemple l'univers
aquatique ou bien la regarder justice ce
sont des animaux mécanique et est ce que
don car dame vit de ses illustrations
oui et bien en fait or dame est
architecte de métier mais bien sûr il
aimerait vivre de sa passion et les
livres de coloriage en plus sont très
tendance en ce moment c'est vraiment pas
mal parce que c'est des activités ça
prend beaucoup de temps de un coloriage
c'est de la détente le coloriage et tous
et tous ces éléments qui sont très
répétitif en fait font beaucoup de bien
donc c'est une servante quelque chose
qui se fait j'ai pas fait ça
spécialement à cause du coc vide mais en
tout cas c'est vrai que ça tombe bien en
ce moment et alors ces liasses car dame
travaille sur d'autres projets oui il
écrit donc son premier livre jeunesse il
a déjà le terrain niveau et je suis
parti sur une idée c'est donc des
extraterrestres qui vont arriver sur
terre et rencontrer les habitants et en
fait ça va être un livre dans lequel il
y aura des rebondissements tout le temps
en ce moment ardam est en train et
d'illustrer page par page son livre pour
celui-là l'illustrateur souhaiterait
être édité par une maison d'édition
il a aussi créé un blog oui le lien
s'affiche en bas de l'écran ce blog a
pour objectif de présenter le livre de
coloriage mais aussi à avoir un retour
direct des internautes et générées ou
pourquoi pas une petite communauté
merci célia gâte son goût d'avoir été
avec nous journalistes pour télé 66
l'équipe artistique du spectacle variété
devait jouer la semaine dernière au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
spectacle inspiré d'une ancienne
émission sur la chanson française crise
sanitaire oblige les représentations à
destination du public ont été annulés
les artistes seront tout de même répété
à la scène nationale pour présenter ce
spectacle aux professionnels l'équipe
s'est engagée dans un nouveau projet la
réalisation d'un film de théâtre pour le
public regardez une captation améliorer
c'est dans ce projet que l'équipe
artistique du spectacle variété
s'élancer
trois jours de tournage au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour allier
cinéma et théâtre le but casser le
quatrième mur pour réaliser un film de
théâtre on va un peu plus loin que la
captation avec l'idée qu'on va aller
pour dehors du théâtre on va suivre
l'actrice principale qui va être sortir
de chez elle prendre les transports en
commun rentrer dans le théâtre et que
des fourbes ainsi choper des bouts de
seins des instants où l'acteur est dans
la loge se prépare pour est dans le
théâtre et et créer un peu une à
orchamps répétition tournage et
représentations tout a été réalisé en
une semaine
objectif pour les artistes se replonger
dans un processus de création et
apporter un plus au projet je trouvais
important que ce soit aussi une création
que ce soit pas seulement filmer la
pièce telle qu'elle est mais que nous on
se remette au travail et qu'on puisse
inventer des choses nouvelles et qu'on
soit dans un mouvement de création
ils ont utilisé la totalité du vieux ils
sont venus en repérage ici pour réécrire
une partie du spectacle et la façon
l'endroit où se déroule certaines
actions certaines scènes et c'est donc
ce sens tactile mais entendent qu'ovide
et non pas juste un spectacle filmé sur
scène dans une ambiance intimiste
pianiste chanteuse et journalistes se
retrouvent pour parler musique c'est
l'émission de télévision des années 60
discorama qui inspiré le spectacle
variétés
vous pouvez me rappeler le nom de la
chanson qui vous a fait gagner
l'eurovision
oui y'a pas de honte y a pas d'eau oui
y'a pas de mon nom nous on a écrit un
spectacle qui dure le temps de
l'émission qui a été diffusée de 1958 à
donc c'est 15 ans d'émission est on est
on tout est centré sur la relation à une
chanteuse donc c'est en fait plusieurs
interviews d'une même chanteuse qui
s'appelle veronica mai et ses 15 ans
comme ça de vie qui passe donc il ya à
la fois la vie de la chanteuse même si
l'avis de la france tous les événements
qui traverse un peu cette histoire en
une heure le film sera diffusé sur le
site du théâtre le 8 avril prochain
c'est la fin de ses 7,8 culture bonne
soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]
à